وينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك ما الذي يجري بالضبط في خرسون
محمد خيرسون هي قد تكون نقطه تحول ان كان
للجيش الاوكراني او حتى للجيش الروسي ولكن
لا نعرف النوايا المضبوطه المهمه ولكن
مؤشرات الميدان هي التي تعطي الفكره
الاساسيه يقال ان هناك ثلاث سينا روايات
ممكنه يعني القرار بالانسحاب الكامل من
هنا فكره تفجير سد نوفا كافكا والذي [__]
15 مليون متر مكعب من المياه وذلك لتغطيه
الانسحاب هذا سيناريو قد يكون بعيد جدا
هسه يعرف الثاني ان يكون هناك تراجع
وانسحاب على مراحل بعد استنزاف الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يتقدم من الشمال هذا
السيناريو اما سيناريو الثالث وهذا اعتقد
انه قد يكون ال- ال- يعني الافضل او
الاكثر همم قبولا او حدوثا هو ان يكون
هناك اخلاء المدينه
تحضيرها لمعركه مدن لمع مدن وشوارع مهمه
جدا كما حدث في ماريو بول لانه لا اعتقد
ان الرئيس بوتين سيعطي خرسون كهديه للرئيس
لينسكي بعد الذي حصل في خارف ربما لهذا
السبب بوتين اليوم اعلن عن ضروره ابعاد
المدنيين عن هذه المعارك لكن هناك تخبط
فيما يتعلق بحضر التجوال او عدم حضره
التجوال من قبل السلطات المحليه هناك
المواليه لموسكو
اخراج المدنيين له عده ابعاد محمد هناك ما
يسمى بالسلافيه اعاده التكوين الاثني
واخذهم باتجاه الروسيه هذه احدى التغيير
الخارطه الاثنيه همم
الديموغرافيه هذا شيء الشيء الاخر هو
اتاحه المجال يعني منع التجول هو فرد نوع
من السريه لاعاده التمركز والتموضع قد
تكون همم مهمه او ليست مهمه ولكن هناك
معلومات تاتي من الجيش تقول ان هناك
التعزيزات لمدينه خرسان باكثر من 1000
جندي لا نعرف نوعيه هذا العسكر هل هو من
المستدعيين الجدد الاحتياط المهم من
النخبه ولكن يبدو ان هناك شيء يحضر لمدينه
خرسان اليوم ام بعد انتهاء التحضير لمعركه
قادمه بعد الشتاء بعد الربيع هذه امور
تقريبا يجب انتظار المؤشرات
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد من بيروت